à 20 heures précises ce soir le
président de la république présentera
ses voeux aux français des voeux qui
cette année seront retransmis pour la
première fois sur internet d'ores et
déjà plusieurs hommes et femmes
politiques de tous bords ont devancé
nicolas sarkozy lorsque la toile devient
un outil de communication incontournable
catherine de manger ils ont tous pris de
vitesse nicolas sarkozy des voeux a
regardé comme il se doit sur internet
chacun y va de son message d'espoir
martine aubry la première en 2011 comme
en 2010 nous serons à vos côtés pour
reconstruire la france forte confiante
et juste que nous attendons c'est
ensemble que nous réussirons françois
bayrou promet des lendemains qui
chantent
dominique de villepin lui a déjà 2012
dans le viseur
c'est presque une déclaration de
candidature vous pouvez compter je crois
comme je sais pouvoir compter sur vous
pour que dès le printemps 2011 nous
soyons en ordre de marche pour préparer
l'alternative 2012 ce sont des voeux
pour la france pour qu'elle retrouve
l'optimisme et le goût de vivre qui
seuls peuvent lui permettre d'affronter
les difficultés au front national
les le pen père et fille ont posté leur
buzz sur internet
je vous invite à redresser la tête à
retrouver notre fierté d'être français
dès 2011 il faut agir pour la france
afin d'éviter le déclin en quelque
quarante années de folle politique de
droite et de gauche emmené
dans quelques minutes se fera autour de
nicolas sarkozy et pour la première fois
les voeux du président seront retransmis
en direct sur internet via le site
dailymotion